there's this SNL skit where Jimmy Fallon
plays you and you're walking into the
Oval Office uh looking cool wearing
wearing Shades and a bulletproof vest to
the song Unbelievable by EMF I don't
know if you've seen it but it's pretty
epic and then uh Trump says that you've
traveled the world representing the
administration but no one has ever heard
you speak so there's a lot of questions
I can ask about that but one of them is
can you introspect why you choose this
lowkey
approach uh of kind of operating behind
the scenes and not speaking much the
public at least at the time you you've
spoken a little bit more and today
you've spoken for a really long time
which I deeply appreciate no it's been a
pleasure to do this and and thank you
for the opportunity to to talk about
these things and so that was a really
funny skit and um you know it's funny
the the thing I got made fun of the most
for that was the Wardrobe and that came
from uh after you know three months in
the administration we would were having
dinner with all the generals and they
were saying you know updating us on the
war with ISIS and general Dumford said
to me after look the president can't
come to see how we're fighting this war
but I'd like to invite you to come with
me to Iraq and come see and would you
come with me I said you know what that's
great I always learned in business you
can't make decisions from just an ivory
Tower you have to go to the front lines
and see what what's actually happening
so I said no problem I'd love to go
meanwhile two days before I'm about to
go the doc from the White House stops by
my office and says we need to get your
blood type what do you my blood type
you're going to an active war zone like
okay so I guess I'm going to war zone I
I didn't really think this thing fully
through so I get on the plane with
Dumford and uh we land in in Iraq and he
looks like gi. Joe he's you know he's a
great uh great General he's very very
well respected in the military and we we
go in and we uh we get on Blackhawk
helicopter they said you know today's a
nice day let's take the uh the sides off
and so I get on the plane and there's a
guy uh you know military service officer
who then takes a machine gun locks it
into a thing takes the bullets puts them
into the gun and it's sitting there
saying we're ready to go and then I'm
looking out and there's like three other
helicopters with guys one was an osprey
with a guy buckled in also with a
machine gun looking out we take off and
we're flying over Baghdad from the
airport to the
Embassy and as we're going I was sitting
in an open air helicopter with the
chairman of the joint chief a staff guys
with machine guns everywhere and this is
a new experience for you you have an
experence I say slightly I mean I was
doing real estate like three months ago
you know now I'm flying over Iraq and
and the chairman says that's Saddam
Hussein's Palace and I look down there's
like a big bomb right through the middle
and then you see the area with the two
swords in the hands I'm saying to myself
like how the hell did I get here like
what what is happening so meanwhile we
end up going to the front lines um to be
with the service uh the Iraqi military
which the US military is working closely
with and I had a meeting that night with
the president of Iraq and so I wore what
do you wear to the front lines in a
battle Zone and uh and also you're the
president so I put a sports jacket on we
land at the um at the front line and
they give me a bulletproof vest that
says kusher on it I tape it I just I I
put it on I go out and uh I covered the
ner so it just said Kush and uh and I
went and I didn't realize they were
taking pictures and so I think the
picture looks pretty epic you was
sunglasses I think I love it so anyway
so that was the funny story behind that
and then uh actually my brother was at
some Society event in New York and uh he
ran into Jimmy Fallon so the two of them
took a selfie together and uh Josh
writes me he says uh uh hanging out with
my older brother in New York you know
I'm trying to explain to him what your
voice sounds like so so it was good so
that was a funny one but I think just
being behind the scenes uh for me just
gave me more maneuverability in the
sense that you know again it goes back
to trust and people knowing that I
wasn't going to try to publicize the
things they were telling me I think it
just gave me more ability to operate
that way and I also realized too like
communicating is a very important skill
uh luckily in Washington there's no
shortage of amazing communicators I
think there were a lot of people who are
much better at me than being
communicators so I was very uh happy
that they were willing to do it because
it wasn't something that I had a lot of
experience with or necessarily I thought
was very I was very good at and so I
kind of just did my job and and and just
focused on getting things
done